rusty how are you always good to see you
always great to see you um
so many questions uh i i am curious what
is it like for you right now after
spending i mean i saw you on the set of
faster like a decade ago i've seen i've
watched your career progress and now
you're at the point after so many years
of being able to say
i want to make this and it gets made
what is that actually like
uh well it's a great position to be in
steve um you know you you and i and our
colleagues we
not only i feel we love what we do and
we are passionate about what we do and
about movies and entertainment uh on
many different levels but i think that
we are also aware of the challenges in
our industry and how
actually difficult it is
to actually get a movie made uh from
beginning to end uh so to be in the
position that i'm in today you and i met
many moons ago on faster uh as i was
trying to
find my way uh in hollywood and um
so yeah so to be in the position that
i'm in today where i have
uh i i do have the ability to say i want
to make this movie and we do get it made
but i will tell you this the
what what allows for that to happen
is
an incredibly
talented group and cadre of people
around me uh who are great at what they
do
in the various positions that i have
them in and also have great
relationships with the studios too so
you know yes it's the ability to say i
want to make this movie and we get it
made but also what's also important and
you know this steve is that we have to
this is where with the studio whether
it's with netflix or disney or universal
or warner brothers dc it all comes down
to you know you've still got to figure
out a pathway uh where the movie is
going to hopefully fingers cross
be accountable in terms of the math uh
and make the studio money not only that
but then also make sure that you're
delivering a movie for the audience so
that's a long answer to say it's a great
position to be in uh i don't take it for
granted and i always want to make sure
that um you know through this because
there's gonna come a time where um
there's there's going to come a time
where you know a lot of times by the way
if it's a movie that i really really
want to make sometimes it's not as easy
as just okay great let's go make it uh
there's a lot of challenges sometimes
that you have to face and have to try
and figure out and then sometimes
uh the movie just doesn't get made
oh i've heard that from so many people
um question about red notice um i think
that a lot of people don't realize what
it really takes to to do these action
set pieces in these movies and really
the time and energy and could you sort
of maybe talk a little bit about
crafting say like the mind sequence in
the third act like what it really takes
to make something like that
it's challenging man it's it's hard to
do but also it's it's what we love to do
what we all love to do uh is challenge
ourselves create these action sequences
in the mind scene in particular the mine
shaft that you're talking about that is
an extraordinary action sequence that
quite frankly
um inspired by indiana jones and raiders
the lost ark and movies like that and
that one in particular um and that that
is vintage ross and thurber um having a
love and an affinity for vintage movies
like that that inspired him as he wrote
the script but you know with that we had
drone shots we had there was a lot going
on and i think that
you know i appreciate you bringing that
up because a lot of times um these
action sequences will come and they will
go but the key is making sure that the
audience feels something in it even if
they can't articulate sometimes like
well there was something unique about
that and how did they get the camera to
fly like that was it on a drone how is
it being controlled a lot of times they
don't ask and don't need to know about
the mechanics but it was very very
challenging i think that with red notice
um
i think with red notice we struck a nice
chord between great action great comedy
which isn't always uh the easiest thing
to do and i also think you know i got to
tell you man
and as a lover of movies i know you you
would appreciate this is
i i've really enjoyed you talked about
my growth and you know you and i have
essentially grown together over the
years uh but i've really enjoyed
watching rawson grow too as well ross
and thurbar already a director because
he really is in that unique cadre of
directors that are rare were they right
from the beginning to the end it's only
their script and then they're the the
the director too as well so he has
really done a great job and i'm very
very proud of him too and i think he did
a great movie oh this is going to be a
massive hit for you guys um a million
other questions but i'm out of time so
i'm just going to say congrats oh man
let's do one more
oh i do have another one last question
um
i may have heard through the grapevine
that you recently watched the director's
cut of black adam and i'm just curious
obviously without visual effects it's
still in a rough state but i am curious
what was your reaction no you have
experience in the editing room you know
what it looks like you know you can tell
but what was your reaction watching like
an early cut of the film
i think we're in a really good place i
think now's the time where um
now's the time there's we take our time
yet there has to be some expediency to
it because we do have to have the movie
ready by next summer i think that jama
delivered a great first cut and you know
black adam was the kind of movie that
it just from beginning it just it had
the makings and the bones to be
something unique and it all started i
think with the ambition but then it all
started with our director and jama
khaletsera and i think that he is an
ambitious director
he again comes from that cadre of
very talented spanish filmmakers who
want to get in and want to disrupt
industry and disrupt craft and he does
it i think in such a great way i also
like
that um
at this point of the cut there is um
there's a clear and defining anchor to
black adam's code and i think that's
really important uh as we look to build
out this
as we look to build out the character as
we look to build out the franchise as we
also look out look to build out the jsa
and introduce them and launch them
properly too as well so
uh
i'm i am
[Music]
happy yet not satisfied and we will
continue to put the work in and um and
the teaser that we showed uh about three
weeks ago i think is is a good indicator
of what's to come
cannot effing wait do that no i can't
wait for you to see it you're gonna
[ __ ] lose your mind and a lot of this
stuff like that problems
like i did yeah you will
dude i i really cannot wait and i know
how long you've put in the decade to
getting this thing made i know what it
means i i'm really so excited
it's oh my man always good talking to
you see you buddy
thanks man later
you